Islam does not belong to Germany
that has the AfD 2.016
written in its basic program
but is still valid today
after the events of the AfD in recent times
let's take a look today at what the party wants
which,
according to the Office for the Protection of the Constitution
1 extremist suspected case is
first of all to Islam there you can still supplement
that the party 2021
wrote in her election program
that they want to prohibit
that Burka and the Cape
may be worn in public
we come to Russia
in the basic program of 2.016 is included
that the relationship with Russia should be developed
but now you think to yourselves
the war has certainly changed
no only briefly
on foreign and security policy can be said
that the AfD wants in general
that Germany is focused on its national interests
reflects what but in a globalized world
is not so easy
hide all others
in addition,
according to the basic program,
the AfD wants to
make a referendum on the euro okay
what does the AfD want in concrete terms for Germany
they want direct democracy
modeled on Switzerland
also they suggest
one should respond to global warming
also have a positive attitude
moreover,
left-wing violence should be targeted
but there is nothing of right-wing violence in the election program
stop gender research
abolish the broadcasting fee
receive the cash
and conscription
The AfD is very critical of abortions
and they must in no way become 1 human right
write in the comments
which areas are of particular interest to you
maybe we will make 1 extra video for this then